hello and welcome to a special e3
edition of swipe on the way sony and
microsoft square up but who came out on
top at the world's biggest gaming
convention
working the floor gaming journalist efa
wilson shares her video diary from the
show
gaming gets real we check out sony's
virtual reality headset
and with military precision we'll be
taking you through the pirates bounty of
new games that were announced at this
year's show
for fans of video games this time of
year is all about e3 with all the
excitement of a massive rock concert
it's an annual mecca for tens of
thousands of people all passionate about
gaming and all wanting to be the first
to know what the big brands have been
working on a year on from the ps4 and
xbox one launches the battle between
sony and microsoft is showing no signs
of cooling off so this time around who's
impressed the most
in the battle to be the best both sony
and microsoft know it's all to play for
when it comes to convincing the industry
and the public which console is best
in carefully choreographed presentations
the new titles came thick and fast
updated classics and indie originals
accompanied with a fair measure of
fighting talk
from its graphic fidelity to its dynamic
social experiences to its deeply
immersive gameplay
destiny will help define this next
generation of gaming we will continue to
invest in bringing new creators to xbox
one
we'll continue to bring you new features
to ensure that xbox live is the only
place where you and your friends will be
able to play the most anticipated
multiplayer games of the year
from batman arkham knight to the 10th
edition of gaming classic mortal kombat
sony are clearly keen to cut their
rivals down to size
a third little big planet promised to
really show what the ps4 can do
little big plants always been about you
know materials you know sponge and wall
and it means that we can really really
make them look brilliant on playstation
4. almost like you want to reach in and
switch them it feels you know it's a
handcrafted game and now it kind of
comes alive on playstation 4.
sony also made attempts to challenge
xbox one as an all-round entertainment
provider touting new hardware that'll
let users stream tv
in return microsoft brought out the big
guns recoding the main games from its
blockbuster sci-fi shooter series halo
to issue a special collection for the
xbox one containing every title but it
was also going big with indie games
we're supporting their creativity by
providing developers with free
development kits free middleware options
and ongoing support that enables
developers to self-publish on xbox one
for the thousands of gaming
professionals who came to la e3 hasn't
disappointed i cannot imagine a more
thorough display of the might of video
games it's pretty awesome
at the moment sony leads the battle
selling 7 million ps4s to the xbox one's
5 million microsoft has slashed prices
to try to level the playing field
combined with the new titles could this
be enough
both consoles there's not too much
difference between them now the
playstation 4 may be a little bit more
powerful maybe in the multi-platform
games like assassin's creed look a
little bit better on playstation 4 but
uh it's it's a pretty it's a pretty even
fight right now with many of the games
mentioned at this year's e3 not actually
coming out until 2015 we might have to
wait a while to work out which console
is the big winner katie spencer sky news
you're watching swipe coming up we check
out sony's virtual reality headset but
first with 720 000 square feet of
exhibition space the madness of the show
floor can be quite hard going on the
ground to give you a feel veteran ethio
games journalist ether wilson offered to
keep a video diary for us welcome to la
where e3 2014 is officially about to
kick off last year it was all about
next-gen hardware it was all with the
new consoles the ps4 and the xbox one
this year
it is 100 about the games
saw some very cool stuff today so uh
batman or good night which um they were
showing off the batmobile the assault
mode versus the sort of pursuit moon
definitely probably one of the
highlights also loot lights of my day
today was um playing alien isolation
which previous alien games the last one
especially alien colonial marines um
was not very good um and it seems like
sega have taken all that on board gone
back to the drawing board listen to what
people actually wanted from an alien's
game but it is just terrifying like you
know i can't remember the last time i
was like literally that you know shook
up by a game so that was that was really
fun and i can't wait to play it again
even if even if i may need a clean pair
of underwear afterwards
i also got to get a look at uh the new
call of duty advanced warfare um they're
only showing off the the single player
at the moment uh here at e3 because
obviously um the multiplayer is kind of
what obviously what a lot of people play
call of duty for um so they like to to
keep that back and sort of uh tease that
a bit more but the single player um
it's looking interesting actually you
know it's obviously it's uh quite
futuristic combat um so they've uh
they've designed a lot of new technology
i'm really excited to see more of uh far
cry 4. i mean i absolutely love the
third game which came out i think last
year um just because it was just so much
fun you know it was a
you could go you know running through
the story as fast as you like but it was
just really fun to sort of explore the
island
so yeah that's e3 2014. um it was a
really good year overall i think for
games especially um obviously last year
it was mostly about the hardware um this
year it was all about the games and
unfortunately um
with a few exceptions we'll have to wait
for a lot of those games until next year
at the earliest but um at least we know
they're coming and they do look pretty
good but uh i'm gonna hit the beach so
see you guys next year
you're watching swipe coming up why
everything isn't awesome in legoland but
first aside from the new titles another
big talking point at e3 this year has
been virtual reality headsets from both
the oculus rift and sony's project
morpheus were on show at dozens of demo
areas for people to try out so we asked
reporter robert gray to take a look
well at e3 2014 you've got some 50 000
folks in here you've got gamers fanboys
media all here to check out all of the
games the bells and whistles here
designed to push the consoles that
debuted in last year's show
now while they're getting a sneak peek
at what's going to come out for the
holiday season we're going to take
actually a look ahead of that and we're
joined by richard marks he is with sony
playstation r d and richard thanks for
joining us thank you thank you so
basically we're going to jump ahead of
this console generation or at least the
future of gaming you guys are bringing
it to the floor here with your project
morpheus and for the uninitiated that's
virtual reality briefly just tell us how
it works we're seeing a demo right here
behind us well basically morpheus is a
headset that you put on your head and
then when you rotate it you get a full
360 view of what's happening in the
virtual world in the game and it uses a
camera to track the colored lights you
see on the headset and there's sensors
inside of the headset as well we combine
that all together and then that creates
the virtual reality experience and you
actually feel yourself in the game i
mean you've got a luge game you've got a
gentleman there playing the deep which
is a shark experience and you're
navigating it really just by turning
your head but you can actually get
butterflies in your stomach yeah when
you go over the hills and the luge
experience you can really feel it feel
that kind of
when your stomach just lurches up and we
should note that you need the
playstation 4 of course for this to work
everyone's going to want to know you
know when this is coming and and you
know what's going to be entailed any
kind of a price ballpark well we're
giving our these prototypes out to our
developers right now to create
experiences and once we get a good set
of experiences and we finalize the
hardware we'll be ready to get it out
there for people we've heard a lot about
virtual reality and going beyond gaming
applications you know maybe you could be
hiking a mountain virtually or or take
yourself to the world cup or somewhere
else like that
how would that work will sony develop
this or would these be partnership
opportunities well our biggest focus is
games because we are playstation but we
are looking at other things you could do
with it for example we've worked with
jpl nasa to make an experience where you
really feel like you're standing on mars
we're talking to other people in
hollywood who are interested in telling
stories using virtual reality so there's
a lot of possibilities i think so maybe
you could visit some of your favorite
places from the movies and feel like
you're you're really there taking the
tour right i mean people get so invested
in these places in these stories and
they could actually feel like they're
walking around those virtual worlds of
course there could be a gaming tie-in as
well maybe so yeah
all right well rick marks thanks so much
for joining us from sony's playstation r
d
you're watching swipe coming up halo new
games we're taking a closer look at the
big titles that have been revealed but
first here's a round up of some of the
other stories you might have missed this
week
the eu's competition regulator is
investigating apple over tax deals it
made with several european countries the
technology giant has agreements with tax
authorities in ireland the netherlands
and luxembourg as part of their strategy
to minimize the tax it pays apple's
irish arrangements meant it paid just
3.7
on non-us income last year although the
headlines are about apple's tax this is
the eu saying right we're now going to
start looking at the way jurisdictions
like the republic of ireland attract
countries companies to do business set
themselves up to pay tax
in their countries we all know using
your phone while driving is a bad idea
and it's hoped this new road safety film
will make people think twice cinema
goers sit watching a car driving down a
quiet road when suddenly they all get it
it's designed to highlight just how
dangerous texting and driving can be
mega upload founder kim.com is offering
a three million pound reward to anyone
who can prove he's been targeted
illegally in the piracy case against him
the tech mogul says the money is for
information which can show u.s and new
zealand authorities acted unlawfully or
in a corrupt manner to build a case in
july he faces an extradition hearing to
see if he'll be sent back to america to
face charges of racketeering money
laundering and copyright theft
black cabbies managed to bring parts of
central london to a standstill when they
staged a protest against google's taxi
app uber when users order a car through
the app the fare is calculated using gps
which cab drivers argue effectively acts
as a meter the problem is legally only
black cabs are allowed to use meters in
london however uber insists it's done
nothing wrong
to prove he's down with the kids
president obama answered questions on
tumblr this week the social media savvy
president invited the microblogging
site's founder to the white house
david carr posted this gif of himself
bumping fists with the president as you
do
awesome everything is awesome
and finally everything is awesome for
fans of the new lego movie outside of
the us
not so much if you're in america in a
row over pricings amazon has put a stop
to pre-orders of this and some of the
other warner bros films in the states
the web giant has been criticized for
the powerful grip it has over contracts
with suppliers
next gen consoles made the headlines
last year at e3 this year it's been all
about the big game releases so which
ones should we be excited about well
down on the show floor we managed to
grab games ross thompson
one of the big themes of this year's e3
is exclusives and on xbox one you've got
sunset overdrive
i used to think this town was boring
it's a very colorful vibrant world
where you play as a character that's
here to save the day where the city
called sunset city said in 2027 has
basically been overtaken by mutants that
have od's on a new energy drink
huge explosion this game for me reminds
me of a tony hawk's meek fed rising meet
saints row but it looks like a whole
load of fun it's a new ip and it's
exclusive to xbox one coming later on
this year
also from microsoft there's the halo
master chief anniversary in preparation
for halo 5
this offers you halos one two three and
four
all there for xbox one users
halo 2 has been fully remastered and
there is a full playlist of over 100
maps that you can make into your own
custom playlist
you have to forget the stories
you also get access to the halo 5 beta
and if you have a halo fan or not this
is a great way of getting yourself back
into the halo franchise for the first
time or if you've already played them
play through it again in preparation for
halo 5.
from sony
you've got littlebigplanet 3.
so littlebigplanet franchise is
exclusive to ps3 and ps4 and the first
time on ps4
and this offers you sac boys returning
plus also three new characters you've
got odd sock who is a very fast-paced
character they can jump up walls
you've got toggle who can basically be
huge or large and get through different
areas and weigh down units
and then you've got swoops who can fly
wherever you need to in the map but also
pick up other characters if you get
stuck
it's all about working together to get
to each of the levels sackboy also has
new abilities there's so many levels
plus all the user-generated content that
will be available for people to do also
lastly
there was uncharted 4.
so not coming out until 2015 but this is
one of the biggest franchises from
naughty dog and for me
it's got success written all over it for
playstation 4. if there's one thing i've
learned in all these years it's there's
no such thing as a surefire plan we've
seen a very quick glimpse trailer of
what this is all about
where drake is awakened in a river of a
jungle
he seems a little bit haggard but he
gets up and there's a commentary that
basically says let's do this one last
time
will it be the end of drake
who knows only time will tell
uncharted 4 a thief's end is going to
come in 2015. we don't know a huge
amount about it now but the hype will
definitely build now we've seen this
first trailer
it's got accessory all over it for the
sony playstation 4 and with it being
exclusive again this could definitely
help sony in the battle of the consoles
thanks ross that's it for this week
remember you can catch all the breaking
tech stories on sky news for ipad or
smartphone apps from sky news.com see
you next time
you